y los discursos de los mandatarios
latinoamericanos en lado no tuvieron en
común el fenómeno migratorio concentrado
en américa central qué impacto tienen
las denuncias de los jefes de estado
cuyos países son de paso de tránsito
hacia eeuu
encantado saludarle bueno pues si es
efectivamente uno de los grandes
problemas que tiene en este momento la
región américa latina y el caribe se ha
incrementado a partir de lo que es la
crisis de la pandemia no solamente la
parte sanitaria sino también la
económica llama mucho la atención que es
evidente que concuerda con la crisis que
está sufrido estados unidos y méxico
particularmente en la frontera de los
dos países por la llegada de haitianos y
sobre todo con la fuerza de uso de la
fuerza de la policía allá en eeuu yo
creo que este es uno de los temas
fundamentales en este momento si usted
se fija a las intervenciones del día de
hoy tanto de giammattei como de cuando
orlando cuando orlando hernández
decirles visite guatemala y el de
honduras señalan a eeuu como culpable de
varios aspectos no solamente a la parte
migratoria sino también en la parte de
narcotráfico en ese sentido creo que son
temas que inclusive llevan su agenda
propia no es decir hay que reconocer y
hay que recordar que en las últimas
semanas en los últimos meses los dos
países centroamericanos han recibido
sanciones de parte de eeuu por temas de
corrupción a algunos de sus funcionarios
y en ese sentido también hay que
contextualizar el hecho de que estos dos
personajes los presidentes estén ante la
asamblea de la onu pues reclamando eeuu
otros temas pero a fin de cuentas tratan
de ajustar cuentas no para llamar mi
siguiente pregunta el presidente de
honduras juan orlando hernández negó
durante sus discursos señalamientos de
narcotráfico y cito transcripciones de
inteligencia de la agencia antidrogas
estadounidense pese a que no está
acusado formalmente pero si es señalado
por los fiscales en nueva york' de ser
un co conspirador que tan sustentada en
esta defensa no pedida del mandatario
bueno y también habría que agregar que
quizás me analizo un poco estas
acusaciones cuando dijo que los
escritores de la serie narcos de netflix
pues tienen estas transcripciones y son
tan reales y que de alguna manera pues
bueno son utilizadas por ellos no creo
que bueno ya hablando
en concreto creo que
uno de sus hermanos si está ya en la
cárcel haya nueva york está siendo
acusado por haber participado en uno de
los carteles del narcotráfico aquí de
méxico en ese sentido que tan reales son
las acusaciones bueno a veces así sucede
con la dea particularmente es una
agencia que presenta grabaciones a veces
se transcripciones a veces son
redacciones que no se entienden pero
bueno hay que tomarlo en serio desde el
punto de vista de que si amerita una
investigación profunda y que sí tenga si
tiene que desahogarse toda la
investigación hasta las últimas
consecuencias bueno y rápidamente el
presidente de venezuela nicolás maduro
pidió otra vez que eeuu y la unión
europea retiren las sanciones
internacionales
y como dijo maduro una agresión
permanente y sistemática de eso es
víctima venezuela
no es evidente que es víctima del
gobierno de nicolás maduro que ha
adoptado prácticamente todos los poderes
desde hace ya algunos años empezando con
la asamblea constituyente y creo que de
alguna forma sus peticiones están
desahogando en la mesa de negociación
que ocurre en mexico promovida por
noruega entre su régimen y su gobierno y
la oposición en ese sentido pues se
recalca al igual que cuba
señala a las sanciones económicas como
el mal económico que está sufriendo sus
respectivos países pero en realidad el
origen también hay que decir es político
es el régimen dictatorial de ambos
países y que de alguna forma pues bueno
otra cosa es la eficiencia de las
sanciones que el propio presidente
barack obama en su momento dijo que al
menos en cubano había funcionado